un drama / crimen y amor y una cinta de
terror corporal hicieron su entrada en
la competencia de cannes
[Música]
ah
el cineasta coreano park chan wok
aterrizó en la competencia de cannes con
su más reciente largometraje decisión to
live una cinta policial con un romance
sutil
[Música]
un hombre cae desde un precipicio ante
el cadáver de su esposo la viuda no
muestra ninguna emoción se trata de un
suicidio o de un asesinato la
investigación se empantana cuando el
detective se enamora de esta misteriosa
mujer
[Música]
versión web brilla por su maestría
técnica sus sorpresas visuales y una
trama compuesta como un rompecabezas
donde no queda claro lo que es
improbable y lo que es real
s
[Música]
el siempre polémico david cronenberg
regresó a cannes luego de ocho años de
ausencia para presentar sus crímenes del
futuro quizás la cinta más radical de
esta edición
y volviendo a mi libertad
esto que he hablado de eso
en un futuro no muy lejano el ser humano
pudiera controlar su cuerpo y crear
órganos a su antojo esa es la
interrogante que plantea cronenberg el
canadiense de 79 años quien ya había
sacudido al actual set en el 96 con
crash regresa con esta cinta gorra
erótica y visceral sobre un dúo de
artistas que se dedica a la ablación de
órganos en público
[Música]
ah
auxilio
cronenberg habla aquí de mutaciones y de
tecnología pero también hace una
radiografía del ser humano tratando de
adaptarse a la destrucción que él mismo
ha creado
camps